sometimes it's good to lose everything
in order to understand what you really
lack
Adventures are never fun while you're
having them
wise people never lose their calmness in
difficult times
and the best way to gain wisdom is to
listen to the thoughts of wise people
Clive Staples Lewis is one of them
friendship is born at the moment when
one man says to another what
you too
I thought I am the only one
someday you will be old enough to start
reading Fairy Tales again
there are far far better things ahead
than any we leave behind
true humility is not thinking less of
yourself
it is thinking of yourself less
nothing you have not given away will
ever really be yours
do not dare not to dare
if you love deeply
you're going to get hurt badly
but it's still worth it
what draws people to be friends is that
they see the same truth
they share it
when we lose one blessing another is
often most unexpectedly given in its
place
everyone gets what they want in life
but not everyone is happy after that
you can't know you can only believe or
not
crying is all right in its way while it
lasts
but you have to stop sooner or later
and then you'll still have to decide
what to do
love is something more Stern and
Splendid than mere kindness
to love is to be vulnerable
atheism turns out to be too simple
if the whole universe has no meaning
we should never have found out that it
has no meaning
what you see and what you hear depends a
great deal on where you are standing
it also depends on what sort of person
you are
if you want to make sure of keeping your
heart intact
you must give it to no one
not even an animal
everyone thinks forgiveness is a lovely
idea until he has something to forgive
God allows us to experience the low
points of life in order to teach us
lessons that we could learn in no other
way
you don't have a soul
you are the soul
you have a body
a children's story that can only be
enjoyed by children
is not a good children's story and the
slightest
God speaks to us face to face only when
we ourselves have a face
it is probably difficult for an egg to
turn into a bird
however
it is incomparably more difficult for
him to learn to fly while remaining an
egg
the task of the modern educator is not
to cut down jungles
but to irrigate deserts
we meet No Ordinary People in our lives
God can't give us peace and happiness
apart from himself
because there is no such thing
it is a good rule after reading a new
book never to allow yourself another new
one till you have read an old one in
between
hell is a door that locks from the
inside
if someone offended you greatly do not
take revenge
wait and fate itself will do everything
for you
it is a very funny thing that the
sleepier you are the longer you take
about getting to bed
money and love
happiness and respect will come into
life
as soon as you find something to do
someone to love
and something to hope for
I believe in Christianity as I believe
the sun has risen
not only because I see it
but because by it I see everything else
if something hurts you keep quiet
otherwise they will hit exactly there
now the trouble about trying to make
yourself stupider than you really are
is that you very often succeed
you never know how much you really
believe anything until it's truth or
falsehood becomes a matter of life and
death to you
relying on God has to begin all over
again every day as if nothing had yet
been done
to love at all is to be vulnerable
love anything and your heart will be
wrong and possibly broken
we have collected these quotes from
Clive Staples Lewis which truly show the
wisdom of this Christian Author he gave
his life to tell this world different
stories about childhood imagination
wisdom and relationship with God